[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the defense scores a win in the florida
prosecution of nfl owner robert kraft
what they never did is hit the stop
button on the recorder
a constitutional violation shuts down a
sex crimes case
plus louisville kentucky prepares for a
decision
on possible criminal charges in the
shooting death of brianna taylor
her family calls for justice it is on
daniel
cameron and the attorney general
of kentucky's office and chaos in the
courtroom is caught on camera
adding extra time to a defendant
sentence law and crime daily covers
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin the defense
for the owner of the new england
patriots scores a legal touchdown
as prosecutors in florida refused to
press forward with a case against robert
kraft
who was charged in connection with a
sting operation at a florida massage
parlor where authorities say
some patrons were paying for sex acts
the police installed and monitored
hidden surveillance cameras inside
private areas of the spa
but the process of how the police built
their case was fraught with errors
and both trial judges and appeals judges
agreed the evidence gathered
should be thrown out of court let's look
back at testimony from a pre-trial
suppression hearing
which exposed the legal problems with
the case
if we had something that was illegal it
was going to be obvious you're looking
into the prying eyes of a detective who
watched a video feed of customers inside
a florida massage parlor
some were said to be paying for sex
others were not
she came in and fairly quickly i
realized that this was probably going to
be a legitimate massage based on her
demeanor defense attorneys for robert
kraft convinced a florida judge
that the police operation was
unconstitutional i think they said which
i have no reason to dispute they were
trying to maintain
the dignity and respect and concern for
the dignity and respect of these people
the fact is that's not what the
constitution requires in any part of
this country the search warrant which
authorized a sting did not require
police to minimize their intrusion into
each patrons privacy
and police did little to minimize
intrusion on their own
the instructions on minimization have to
be put in the affidavit
and or the warrant it has to be very
clear and set out and explain
what it is you do to prevent innocent
people
or innocent conduct from being captured
the judge said detectives here simply
saw and recorded too much the spa
advertised services for women clients
and
in fact more than one woman had a
significant portion
of her spa time viewed by a detective
and the entirety of her spa time
recorded and placed in jupiter police
department records
failing to consider and include
instructions on minimizing the impact on
women
is a serious flaw in the search warrant
the judge's order went on to criticize
the viewing and recording of the
legitimate massages of male clients as
well
prosecutors unsuccessfully tried to
convince the judge that they did
minimize their intrusion
officers want as much evidence as they
can get they called us on the phone
they told us what we had we said shut it
down because
four and a half days was plenty the
judge suppressed the recording
and the subsequent traffic stop which
identified kraft
and ultimately the trial judge and the
appeals court ruled the evidence was
unconstitutionally gathered and had to
be suppressed terry austin explains the
arguments
from both sides at the appeals court
level terry
the arguments deal actually aaron with
the fourth amendment which requires a
judge
who issues a warrant to specifically
name what officers can
seize the legal issue is whether the
judge who signed the original warrant
told the police to use techniques to
minimize law enforcement intrusion
into the privacy of legitimate spa
customers
here's how the state attempted to argue
that the operation
was constitutional there simply was no
fourth amendment violation here
either as a matter of the warrant clause
because these warrants contained
everything
that the constitution requires or as a
matter of the reasonableness clause
because given what police knew at the
time and given the circumstances
confronting them in the difficulties of
this
unique kind of search their conduct was
lawful
second even if you find that there was
some
police misconduct the remedy could not
possibly be
the extreme remedy of total suppression
that these defendants
urge on you and that's because of the
good faith exception
because of ordinary fourth amendment
standing principles
and because of the limited nature of
suppression that applies in a case of
this nature but the defendant's
arguments in kraft and zang
turn on four or five federal court of
appeals decisions which of course were
not binding on the lower court
and are not binding on this court and
some of those decisions
suggest that the text of the war clause
requires
what courts have called talismanic
minimization language
in the the scope of the war itself and
the plaintext of the warn itself
but that's not correct and in fact there
is a dispute amongst
even federal judges about whether or not
the war clause imposes that additional
requirement that is not
anywhere within the text of the war
defense attorneys for robert kraft say
the prosecutor told the officers to
quote
record everything the defense argued
that was unconstitutional
so the state tries to say look we did
minimize we engaged in extrinsic
minimization we only monitored for 30
days
but what they never did is hit the stop
button on the recorder
they recorded for 60 straight days
the u.s supreme court has made it clear
that the purpose of the exclusionary
rule is to
deter police misconduct so in this case
when you have
intentional disregard of the
minimization requirement
they would serve the purpose of
deterring future police misconduct
to ensure that law enforcement does not
in the future blatantly disregard
the minimization requirements that apply
to video surveillance
a rather shocking moment in the
courtroom during the suppression hearing
last year when craft's attorney asked a
cop who pulled him over
about statements captured on his
body-worn camera during the operation
for that side of this story returned to
brian buckmeyer the defense accused an
officer of making up a reason to pull
over some of the defendants
suspected of paying for sex acts at the
spa where the sting took place
now the officers grill the officer was
grilled when they took to the stand
about a radio transmission regarding
another defendant
in court it looked like another point
for the defense but
later prosecutors accused the defense of
mischaracterizing the radio transmission
here's the defense line of questioning
during a pre-trial hearing
i'm asking you do you recall saying
it doesn't matter in response to that i
can make some
you said this that i said that during
the robert craft traffic
no right this traffic stop right before
that the traffic stop right before that
when your audio was on
before you ever knew you were going to
stop mr craft okay
i i truly i'm sorry i remember saying
that okay
and i i i don't i would if i said it i
wouldn't even know the context of how it
was said and
obviously and more of a uh joke with
however you heard that okay so that was
okay so so you whether it was a joke or
not
um you don't have a i don't have a
recollection of it so i'm not going to
tell you
that who i was talking to or whatever i
have zero recollection that i said
okay brian so the cop was trying to
basically explain that he had to find
another reason to pull over
suspects such as maybe failing to stop
at a stop sign
something like that some some pretextual
reason
here that's how they were identifying
the people they caught on the video in
the spot
you have some constitutional issues with
this exactly like
what the defense is doing here is trying
to pigeonhole the officer to say why did
you stop them
obviously there was a paper trail
probably prior depositions
and what you're seeing here is that
officer floundering because they know
that something is incorrect this is not
going to pass constitutional muster
and that's why this case or at least
part of the reason why this case
ended the way that it did so terry the
defense in the appeal accused the cops
of basically flatly lying in their
search warrant application by citing a
case on minimization
this whole legal concept of minimization
which the cops then admitted on the
stand that they never actually read so
terry how is it that the cops are
submitting applications saying
we're going to use this case and then
they say we never read the case
well that's a problem aaron you know the
officers should know the techniques
involved with minimizing the intrusion
to the other customers and invading
their privacy
and if they say they knew and they
understood and they're citing a case
which outlines how you should be doing
the minimalization and it turns out they
didn't actually read those cases
then they're lying and that is a big
problem brian your reaction to this
quickly prosecutors are refusing
another layer of appeal here so the case
is all but
formally dropped prosecutors are saying
they don't want to risk
stacking up higher level precedent
against future cases
your reaction i mean that's smart
because even myself here in new york i'm
thinking how can i get that case law
to apply to my clients here in brooklyn
and they understand that
every defense attorney in their county
in their state is salivating
at that ruling because it's going to
help a lot of people who don't have
craft money you want this precedent all
over the country well still ahead on law
and crime daily crazy courtroom moments
and explosive drama but first louisville
kentucky bracing for a decision on
whether to bring criminal charges in the
shooting death
of brianna taylor that's when we return
on law and crime daily
plywood boards on windows and concrete
barriers now lining the streets of
louisville kentucky as the city braces
for possible backlash
to a possible announcement by the state
attorney general in the police shooting
death
of briana taylor taylor was killed in
her home when officers executed a no
knock warrant
those officers are now under internal
investigation and may
also be the subjects of a secret grand
jury probe into what went wrong
among the officers are sergeant jonathan
mattingly who was
shot during the raid but who has since
recovered detective miles cosgrove was
placed on administrative leave along
with mattingly
former officer brett hatkinson was fired
for blindly shooting 10 rounds
into taylor's apartment taylor's family
was awarded a record 12 million dollar
civil settlement
and a wrongful death suit against the
city but an attorney for her family said
recently that justice cannot end there
we still are demanding that kentucky
attorney general
daniel cameron bring charges immediately
against the police officers that
murdered brianna taylor
justice delayed is justice denied and at
the very minimum
second degree manslaughter charges
because we want full justice
for brigham brianna taylor not just
partial justice
as part of the settlement the city and
police agreed to make several reforms
including how search warrants are
conducted but as part of that settlement
the city did not have to admit faults
currently in our process a search
warrant is applied for by the officer
it is reviewed by a potentially
commanding officer in many cases
but not necessarily always
in the instant it is signed off by a
commanding officer that may be
by somebody in an acting capacity what
this agreement does
is solidify that it will be an actual
commanding officer of the rank of
sergeant or above
this agreement or settlement agreement
does not
say that there was any wrongdoing done
in this case it's just an acknowledgment
of the need for reform and the need for
a settlement to take place
brian and terry back again for analysis
so brian all of these preparations this
is going to be a
monumental announcement either way it
goes down
yeah and to be honest i'm too jaded to
believe they're going to come with an
indictment
i believe a diamond should be here i
believe that manslaughter
and the second degree or reckless
homicide should be there but they're
they're giving too much the 12 million
dollars the new law reform the boarding
up of the wall is a preparation
it makes me think that someone knows and
i don't want to add a conspiracy theory
out there
but it makes me feel that we're not
going to get the indictment that people
are thinking is going to come down
terry should charges come in this case
your thoughts
you know i think there should be some
action against the police officers i do
think there should be some charges
you know they were reckless in firing
you know 10 rounds into
the house not knowing exactly who was in
or who they may be hitting so
the civil settlement is well and good
but i do think that in order to change
the actions of the police we need to
take action
against the police yeah there needs to
be some individual accountability here
and brian you're shaking your head terry
you're agreeing with me something just
doesn't sit right with this whole
concept
that there's a warrant secured on
sketchy grounds brian
because they're looking for drugs where
were the drugs
exactly exactly
there's a lot wrong with here from the
from the inauguration of the of the
of the warrant to how it was filled out
it's all
wrong we need some more transparency in
this case
i want to see exactly what's going on
how do they secure the war i want to see
more paperwork in this one terry
i know i agree with you we need to see
more paperwork and we need to see
charges filed against the police
officers
we will wait and see if that
announcement comes this week there's no
telling if and when it indeed is going
to come and still ahead here on law on
crime daily
watch as a florida sheriff tries to
explain the strange conduct
of one of his own deputies now facing
charges and we go inside some of the
nation's courtrooms
as proceedings turn to chaos
cameras and courthouses capture a lot of
things verdicts arguments of law and
sometimes they capture mayhem
here's such a moment brought to us by
court cam a law and crime series
which airs on the a e network here is
dan abrams
we go to the veterans memorial
courthouse in lansing michigan
for the trial of 35 year old joshua
harding
who's been charged with two counts of
sexual assault
[Music]
there's harding two prosecutors
represent the state
including jonathan roth who prior to
sentencing
asked the court to consider a sentence
on the higher end of the guidelines
at the far end of the table is detective
brian kanan the lead investigator in the
case against harding
the jury's reached a decision in one of
the cases
and is about to read its verdict
in under eight seconds so much has
happened
let's look at it again if you look a
little closer
you can see harding removed something
from inside his sleeve
turns out harding is holding a metal
shank harding storms the prosecutor's
table
headed straight for assistant d.a roth
if not for the quick reflexes of
detective kanan
roth could have sustained serious
injuries
two court deputies immediately take
action to help bring
harding who stands six six and weighs
280
to the ground
[Music]
watch as roth removes his glasses to
take a step
towards the scrum a spectator points
something out to roth
it's the shank
meanwhile kanan and the two bailiffs are
still wrestling with harding
it took about 30 seconds to eventually
cuff
and remove the defendant from the
courtroom
this brazen attack brought harding an
additional charge of assault with intent
to murder
to which he pled guilty as for the
original charges
harding was found guilty of
second-degree criminal sexual conduct
and is now serving a combined sentence
of 44 years at a state prison
the earliest he could be released is the
year 2064.
authorities are unsure how harding got
the weapon into the courthouse
because harding was in police custody
during the trial he did not have to pass
through a metal detector
upon entering the courthouse he also was
not required to wear handcuffs
and when we come back the mother of a
slain georgia man says others are
exploiting
her son's death
[Music]
the jacksonville florida sheriff's
office arresting one of their own
officers in a bizarre
case said to involve bribery officer
brian pace resigned from the force after
his superiors say they caught him trying
to solicit
a female crime victim for inappropriate
photographs
the victim a woman had her cell phone
stolen she merely wanted it back
but when pace allegedly asked her for
the illegal trade for photos she filed a
complaint
here's the under sheriff describing what
happened
he answered a call for police service
back at the beginning of may
where he had contact with a female
victim who had
had misplaced or had some property
stolen
he took a report basically over the
phone
and then he re-initiated contact with
her shortly thereafter
claiming to have her property and that
he would
give her her property back if she would
send him some inappropriate
photographs via the phone
a long conversation between the two
integrity special investigations got
involved conducting investigation
the last piece of the investigation led
to a culmination last night
where he asked to actually meet the
victim
claiming he was going to give her her
property and
when they he pulled up he was arrested
shortly thereafter
so he was arrested for the felony he
resigned from his position with the
agency as i always try to tell you
ladies and gentlemen that he he will not
then be employed it will not be this
long process
of why is he still working for the
jacksonville sheriff's office he elected
to resign from his position therefore he
will not have the civil service
protections and we have to go through
that
that long ordeal and that was a
courageous complaint and finally now to
a dispute involving the memory of ahmad
arbury gunned down on a nearby road
after looking at a house
being built in georgia cnn is reporting
that arbury's childhood friends have
filed a trademark registration for the
phrase
i run with mod the application was filed
may 9
less than two days after arrest warrants
were issued for defendants gregory and
travis mcmichael
cnn says arbury's mother is complaining
that the friends
who are attempting to register the
trademark are trying to profit
from arbory's death the friends say
they're trying to preserve the mark
since one of their team members uttered
it
and to preserve it for arbury's mother
and father back now with brian and terry
so terry
there's a bit of a distinct battle
between the mother and the father of
ahmad arbury here the friends say that
both parents would benefit from this
rather than just the mother
said to be benefiting from the gofundme
without the father but the big question
is
should this mark be given federal
trademark protection
well yeah i think it should be but the
question is whether or not it should be
given to the friend who's registering it
or to the ahmad aubrey family because
technically a trademark or a service
mark it's a word that
is protected and it identifies the
source of the goods
and i think the family could argue here
the source of the goods is a mod
aubry himself the source is his name and
they could easily
argue that someone is trying to take
advantage of his name so
i do think they have a good argument i
do think they
and their lawyers should jump on top of
this and register
the mark themselves you could always
contest the registration and again
trademark law is primarily for consumer
protection when you buy something you
want to know where it's coming from
uh brian your thoughts on this should
the friends get the mark or should it go
to the family
yeah so terry is definitely the expert
on this but i'll try to dip my toe into
this
unless there's some sort of contractual
agreement prior to making that trademark
i think it's going to be a very long and
drawn out legal battle for the family
and i'm not sure they'll actually come
out on top end of the day it's going to
be difficult
it's another case for us to watch here
in law and crime daily good analysis and
thank you for joining us we'll see you
next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
i'm dan abrams and this is the lawn
crime network
the only 24 7 network with expert legal
analysis
and gavel to gavel live trial coverage
watch the law on crime network
today
[Music]
you